alary faut passer
petites misères seront passagers tout ça
s'arrangera
vous voyez souvent à la télévision
vous n'entendez que lui à la radio mais
vous ne savez pas grand chose de lui
et voyez j'habite rang et la wii une
fatigue intense pour moi un petit peu
oui parce qu'on s'est rencontrés à quel
âge 700 millions de chinois
à
ma vie mon chéri mon mal de tête pour
moins de fois j comme celle là c'est la
vie c'est vrai que c'est timide oui
c'est vrai faux timide eu un petit peu
plus que la politesse mais timide comme
toujours ou est-ce que à ce que les
succès fait que ça change
le succès ne change pas du tout ce qui
peut me changer ces quelques bières 400
millions de noirs
yves elle sombre une histoire on saura
pourquoi ya t-il
d'après toi après la vie enfin après
l'amour tu préfères sûr je veux bien les
voir